welcome back to the big saturday show
tonight the sudden tragic death of a
10th grader in connecticut is raising
questions about the safety of high
school ice hockey teddy balkan was
playing in a game thursday night when
the deadly accident occurred the local
police captain saying quote a player
from the other team who fell to the ice
and there was another player who was
near the down player he was unable to
stop and collided with the player who
fell a skate cut balkan's neck the local
community and the hockey community writ
large in mourning now with professional
players posting photos of their hockey
sticks on social media under the hashtag
sticks out for teddy in tribute and this
is just an unimaginably sad tragic story
guys obviously jimmy you're a parent
you're also a sports fan
how does this story hit you
this is a really challenging thing to
tackle man because as a parent you
understand that they're going through
some unimaginable anguish
and i think what happens to a lot of
people in this situation is the story
makes you feel so helpless that we start
looking around for some type of a
villain some type of you know rule or
regulation we can scrutinize because it
makes it feel like there's something we
can be doing here to you know avenge the
way we feel and avenge the way not only
this poor kid's parents feel but even
the kid who skated into him who
obviously didn't get on the ice looking
for this to ensue
and it really is difficult because it's
youth sports and there is an inherent
risk to playing them that being said
this is not something that anyone ever
signed up for bargained for or dreamed
that could happen so you do hope uh you
know we take a closer look at this i
don't know that there's going to be a
solve because this is such a one in a
trillion tragedy
and i think that's the most
heartbreaking part for all of us is
there's not a lot we can do other than
hopefully step up the way a lot of these
professional teams have by posting
photos that was you know heartening you
got professional teams like the rangers
and the devils and of course
non-professional teams like the
islanders but the point is it was nice
to see people acknowledge this
yeah and alicia you look at the photos
of this kid so much life his whole life
stretching out in front of him and then
it ends in an instant and it really is
a freak accident right there's no
avoiding this this is a fast sport
this is a contact sport
this is unbelievably unlikely to occur
and i understand the the instinct for
some people to say well maybe we need to
tighten up some of the rules or maybe
this isn't safe there are thousands of
hockey games played every single day
this type of thing is making news
because it's so rare you're also a
parent how do you grapple with some of
these
emotions and some of these
considerations you know you said exactly
what i say to my kids when i'm trying to
explain something that is so incredibly
tragic and it just defies the
imagination you can't really even
imagine that it would happen is that i i
would i tell mine because i have
teenagers at home i'm a parent to three
tenth graders the same
grade as as teddy and what i tell them
is this is on the news because it is so
rare this is not something that happens
all the time
that does not help in any way the
heartbreak that this family and this
community is experiencing from a broader
perspective it is incredibly rare and
it's so so hard sports does come with
inherent risks
that's just the nature of sports and
every now and then every now and then
our hearts break
yeah and i'm a big hockey fan hockey
players are known to be a very
close-knit community which is why you're
seeing this outpouring including from
some of these professional franchises
and lisa jimmy touch on this a little
bit
of course our hearts go out to teddy's
family i mean you just truly cannot
imagine there also i think has to be
some rallying around whoever the kid was
who had this accident who caused it it's
not his fault this was never anyone's
intent but my goodness that will be with
that individual that young man for the
rest of his life too
now that's such a good point and look
they're 10th graders so these you guys
are are babies and teddy's dad was in
attendance so praying for him and his
family as well
i can't even imagine that and look
anytime we have tragedy the natural
response is well what could we have done
to prevent it what can we do in the
future and unfortunately with freak
accidents like this sometimes there's
nothing we can do and that's almost the
hardest conclusion to come to you know
my understanding is even wearing you
know a neck guard doesn't prevent from
lacerations and as was previously
pointed out you know sports there's
inherent risk i played field hockey i've
been hit in the head with field hockey
balls i tore my acl playing lacrosse but
then alternatively i've slipped in the
shower and gotten a concussion so life
is full of risk sports are full of risk
and and sadly i don't think there was
much that could have been done to
prevent this but as we should all pray
for his family pray for the young man
who you know was involved in this and as
you pointed out i just cannot imagine
having to go through that in life the
10th grade is so young so just praying
for everyone involved in this it's it's
really sad
yeah
absolutely and we got to leave it there